buster posey making history tonight 1
000 games behind the plate for the
giants first to ever do that in that
uniform on the hill tonight for the
giants making his first
start here in san francisco is alex wood
the 30 year old left-hander he's in his
eighth year at the big league level six
four 210 pounder
when you're facing wood you're going to
see a fastball that can go anywhere from
89 to 93 miles per hour he will sink and
cut that fastball
he's got a a change-up and a curveball
that are both
very good off speed pitches that he has
very good command with
jazz is in at 320 after going
one for four and striking out twice last
night three doubles a triple three
homers he's knocked in six
and here's a towering fly ball long way
back right center field jazz chisholm
hits it into mccovey cove it's his first
career
leadoff home run the marlins who hadn't
homered in a week
grab a one nothing lead one batter in
tonight well jazz has just
unloaded what a way to start a gay
game in the bay
a long home run did that get into the
water on the fly i think is the question
it was a
no doubter and there aren't too many no
doubters in san francisco
but my oh my what a swing sandy
alcantara has a run to work with thanks
to chaz chisholm junior's home run his
fifth start in 2021 he's gone six
innings
at least in 19 of his last 21
outings and sandy's issued a two-out
free pass here to put runners in first
and second put in the ground to the
second baseman jazz gathers it in
throws on to first not contras out of
the inning so a couple of strikeouts a
hit
a walk but nothing across one nothing
miami
is duvall weights he struck him out
swinging nice slider
and there is one away got him he got
birdie to chase
two down and here's brinson in a check
swing and he went around with it strike
three the slider that ran off the inside
corner
and brinson could not check his swing in
time
man at first for ustremski who had a
terrific year last year but off to a
sluggish start here in 2021
here's a swing and a drive by yostremski
to left field and pretty deep
going back to the wall and it's gone
just over the wall and maybe with a push
from the wind
a home run mike yostremski to the
opposite field
giants take a two to one lead nikki
stremski hit it hard no doubt but he is
very high and it just hung
and hung and hung and kept traveling and
finally
over the wall so a chance for adam
duvall could turn this game around one
big swing
absolutely he can that's a lot of power
coming from duvall swing and a miss on
the curve strike three
he gets duvall for the second time in
this game here's john bertie
up the middle crawford he's got it
behind the bag
he got him well the other thing you
notice and i'm sure crawford did
is that birdie got out of the box really
quick
and you know that as an infielder just
by the way he swings at a pitch in
his contact top of the order here we go
third time around
gabby la stella ustremski and flores
bounce involved the right of jazz
chisholm second baseman has it russia's
the first and lastella's out
route number one here in the fifth
inning yeah while the uh
marlins kind of tread water here and
wait for the alfaros and the andersons
and the martes of the world they're
gonna have to rely on
their defense and their pitching and
some timely hitting
seven strikeouts for wood working on a
one-hitter pitching with a
2-1 lead and it'll come to jazz chisholm
swinging a line drive right back to wood
who makes the catch
a screening liner right back to the
pitcher it caught him
he didn't catch it it caught him and
chis
near home play with his hand on his head
he says are you kidding me
how can you catch that ball adam simber
out of the bullpen marlins down
2-1 last to the sixth inning giants had
first and third with nobody out they now
have first and third with two outs
and simber is going to face austin
slater simba who's
done a nice job the slater bouncy ball
to third
birdies got it across the first and
simmer gets out of the inning
giants in first and third with nobody
out but they couldn't add to their
lead that's some pitching by detweiler
and now simba
here's adam duvall who is struck out
twice hit to left center field
kind of hanging for austin slater he's
over and makes a catch
and what a great first home start alex
wood went seven innings gave up
one hit now it was a lead off home run
to start the game by jazz chisholm that
is the only hit
better put men at the corners will get
the righty floors because flores hits a
lighter into center field base hit
duvonne comes in to score wilmer flores
comes through
after the intentional walk the strategy
foiled 3-1
giants wilmer just hit a bullet right
back up the middle richard bleyer the
left-hander out of the bullpen against
brandon belt
to on one out softly toward the middle
on the ground pass the diving attempt
of jazz chisholm into center field here
comes ustremski around third
and he'll score without a play granted
belt did not hit it very hard
but he placed it perfectly it's four to
one giants
just a little chopper past the mound and
chisholm
who was shady belt to pull and playing
in a little bit
had no angle rojas the shortstop went
over to cover the bag at second
he had no chance to get the ball and
belt just snuck it on through
a matchup where if ruff could get a ball
in the air you got wilmer flores at
third if it's deep enough maybe you get
another run home
swings hits a fly ball right center
field we'll see if it's deep enough
cooper comes in
makes a catch flores tags here comes the
throw it's well offline
and cut off by the first baseman aguilar
on top of the mound
sacrifice fly for darren ruff five to
one giants
that's why you use the pinch hitter
there
plus you've already put duvonne in the
game mauricio can play center to give
you
your best defense slide slater over the
left one cory dickerson
is going to hit for the pitcher and then
you get the top of the order so these
are the best hitters that the marlins
have
maybe that's part of the calculus to
bring jake mcgee into the game
he's getting ready so here he is five to
one giants
inning number nine got him
one out in the night perfect two pitch
on the outside corner
and a quality hitter like corey
dickerson goes up there and gets three
pitched and
doesn't even get a swing at strike three
that's a rough at bat
so now here is jesus aguilar
right-handed batter hit high in the air
deep down the left field line toward the
corner at the wall
and gone a home run he just did
get it out of there first of the year
finally for azusa zaghilar
and it's five to three into the first
row just over the outstretched arm in
the left field of darren
got him and the giants continue to play
terrific baseball at home they're now
seven and one